The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: OK, so
let me remind you where
we were before spring break.
So first of all, there's a
posting with the project list.
Feel free to pick a project
as soon as you're ready.
Send me your choice.
Problem set number 3 due today.
Problem set number 4
is posted this morning.
It will be due in two
weeks, plus two days so,
two weeks from now there's
actually a holiday,
so it will be due
on that Thursday.
Last time, we were talking about
two-nucleon effective field
theory.
So this was a
nonrelativistic field theory.
Both of these terms here in
the action were the same size.
They were the same relevance.
And we talked about
that last time.
So in HQET, it would
just be the first term,
but in this case
of two nucleons,
we actually need the
kinetic term, as well,
and both of these terms
are equally important.
And that basically means
that in this type of system
the time derivatives
and spatial derivatives
are counted differently.
But you can organize
the field theory
using equations of motion
so that these are just
local operators with
spatial derivatives.
So you basically deal with
the time derivatives once
and for all, and you could
always use equations of motion
to eliminate them there.
And so you just have really
this one time derivative.
This theory is
particularly simple
if we neglect the
relativistic corrections,
and that's because
it's not-- because it's
a nonrelativistic
field theory, we just
have these bubble diagrams.
And they're just
contact interaction,
so they all decouple from
each other, so at N-loop order
we can just write down
what the loops are.
We talked about the fact
that, in terms of power
counting things, where it
could be a little subtle,
and that was related also
to a power divergence that
occurs in this diagram, and
we could track that power
divergence by using
particular schemes that
gave this extra mu r term, and
I won't repeat all that story.
But that led us to adding
a finite counterterm
to this bubble diagram to track
the power law divergent term,
and that allowed us to come up
with a power accounting that
would take into account systems
where the scattering length is
large, or in particular,
the scattering length times
momentum is greater than 1, and
in these two-nucleon systems
that's exactly the
scenario that we're in.
So what we then had
was a power counting
that assigned the
very first operator
to scale like 1 over
a power of momentum.
So not like 1 over the
power of a large scale,
but actually 1 over a power of
something small, the momentum
but we're interested
in studying.
So it's enhanced in
the power counting
that we wanted to adopt.
And that meant
basically that you
had to treat this one coupling,
c 0, nonperturbatively.
You summed it up to all
orders, so the term here
comes from adding
up all the diagrams
with any number of bubbles, and
that all give this first term.
And then the rest
of the couplings
are treated perturbatively,
the higher derivative term.
So a term, c 2, which
comes with grad squared,
and that gives this
extra p squared.
And the numerator here gets
treated perturbatively,
and there's this term, and
then there's higher terms.
And that's how we could
organize this theory,
and this sums up all
these powers of a times p,
these denominators that
I'm showing you there.
So what I want to do for
the first part of today
is just really continue with
this effective field theory
and talk about a few
more of its features.
First I want to start
with symmetries,
and then we'll talk about
something called the deuteron.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the relevance
of the kinetic term.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So other than
getting pinch singularity
in your integrals,
is there, I don't
know, a more power
counting-friendly kind
of argument for [INAUDIBLE]?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, so you
can think about it like--
really, what we're doing here
is nonrelativistic quantum
mechanics.
And if you think about
nonrelativistic quantum
mechanics, you think about,
like, the virial theorem.
You're used to
thinking about the fact
that kinetic energy
and potential energy
are equally relevant, right?
So from a physics
standpoint, if I
didn't want to
talk about diagrams
or I just wanted to make a
physics argument for why that
would be the right thing to
do, I could simply tell you,
I want nonrelativistic quantum
mechanics at lowest order.
This is a system with
two heavy particles,
so that's which the
physics should be.
If you start with
the wrong theory,
then you run into
problems, and that's
kind of what we
saw if we started
with an HQET-like reasoning.
Then we see this
pinch singularity,
which is resolved
by the kinetic term.
AUDIENCE: OK, then, why is it
that nonrelativistic quantum
mechanics has the form
that it does, then?
IAIN STEWART: Why does
nonrelativistic quantum
mechanics have the
form that it does?
[CHUCKLES]
AUDIENCE: I know, I just--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah,
so think about it
from the following
point of view.
So when we just had this term,
what was the particle doing?
When we just had the partial
t term, it's like a source.
We had a single
source sitting there,
and we were interacting with
it with some light stuff.
That was HQET.
Here we have two
sources, and they have
to interact with each other.
And the problem is
that two sources
interacting with
each other, really,
the kinetic energy
becomes a relevant thing.
It's not-- I mean, it's actually
a little more subtle than that,
if you really want to go
into it in a gauge theory.
There's sort of situations where
these two heavy sources act
like two heavy
sources, like HQET,
and there's situations
where they wiggle.
And the situations
where they wiggle
are exactly the things that
the Schrodinger equation
is giving you.
If you like-- yeah, so
to say it precisely,
the potential between
the two heavy particles,
for the purposes of
figuring out that potential,
you can treat them
as static, as fixed.
But then, once you
have that potential,
these bubble diagrams
are kind of the way
in which that potential
gets iterated into the thing
that you would get from solving
the Schrodinger equation.
So solving the
Schrodinger equation,
you're effectively
treating the potential
to all orders in this series,
exactly this bubble series.
And when you solve that you
need to include the kinetic,
this grad squared over
2m, for the same reason
that it's a relevant thing to
include in quantum mechanics.
OK, good.
Good project choice.
I urge you-- no.
[CHUCKLES]
OK, so let's talk about some of
the symmetries of this theory,
which are kind of interesting.
So the first one is that
this theory actually
has a nonrelativistic
conformal invariance.
So what is a nonrelativistic
conformal invariance?
So this is an extension
of the Galilean group,
rather than the Poincaré group.
So we have the
usual translations.
We have rotations.
We don't have Lorentz
boosts, but we
do Galilean boosts for a
nonrelativistic system,
like this.
So what would those be?
So under a Galilean
boost, time is not changed
and the spatial
coordinates are changed.
And then there's
additional generators
that you have in a
conformal invariance.
One is a scale
transformation, one generator.
And the way that the
scale transformation works
is as follows.
You rescale the coordinates
by some-- let's call
it e to the s.
But you have to rescale time
differently, by e to the 2s.
And the reason that
you have to do that
is exactly because
these two terms
should be treated the same.
So you have to rescale
time twice as much
as you rescale the spatial
derivatives, if you like,
so that's what gives
rise to the 2 there.
And that just goes to the
heart of sort of counting
time and space differently.
And then, finally, there
is a conformal generator.
And there's actually
only one generator
in this nonrelativistic case.
And basically what this
generator corresponds to
is a shift of inverse time and
then a corresponding change
to the coordinates.
And if you take all
these things together,
it's actually something
called the Schrodinger group.
And the theory we've
been talking about
actually has this
nonrelativistic conformal
symmetry, if a goes to infinity.
So I'm not going to spend a
lot of time talking about this,
but just to give you some of
the ideas of what is going on.
If you look back last time at
our solutions for this coupling
constant, and you take
a goes to infinity,
that's a perfectly smooth limit.
You can do that.
And then the coupling, c 0 of
mu, has no free parameters.
It's just given
by 4 pi over m mu.
And that corresponds
to sitting at this--
what I call-- what
we last time saw
was a fixed point of
the beta function.
And at that fixed point,
there's enhanced symmetry, which
is this conformal symmetry.
And basically what you can
show is that, if you scale here
mu just like it was a momentum--
so mu goes to e to the s mu--
then the Lagrangian
is scale-invariant.
My notation up there
would be minus s.
OK?
And that is basically kind of
the same thing as making it
into a relevant coupling.
Once it's got no
free parameters,
then you can sort
of see that, if I
have a certain scaling
that makes the free theory
Schrodinger-invariant, which
is-- so the Schrodinger
group is the symmetry group of
the free Schrodinger equation,
so just this term and this term.
Then the question is,
what interactions can you
add that would
preserve that symmetry?
And I'm just telling you that,
in terms of just the scale
transformation,
you could-- if you
are able to scale the
coupling in some way,
in particular to make it a
relevant interaction, then that
will make it a
scale-invariant theory.
And so the ability to
scale this coupling
because you scale
this mu allows it
to be a scale-invariant theory.
It's a little harder to
see that it's conformal,
but you can work that out, too.
Scale-invariant theories tend
to be conformal-invariant,
and the same is true of this
nonrelativistic conformal
invariance.
So if you sort of
add up the bubbles
that we were talking
about, then you
find in general in amplitude,
which is this thing that
has a square root--
but if I'm not
particular to what
frame I'm in now, if I just
write it for a general frame--
before we write it for
the center of mass frame,
now let me write it
for a general frame.
Then it would look like this.
And that thing
goes like 1 over p,
so it has-- and again,
e's scale differently
than p's, so this thing
has the right scaling
for a scale-invariant amplitude.
And it turns out,
if you do work out
the conformal transformation,
it's also conformal-invariant.
And I'm not going
to go through that,
but I've posted a reference
to show you how it works.
And basically what this leads
to is a cross-section, which
is 4 pi over p squared, which
is the scale-invariant version
of a cross-section, where the
cross-section units are just
set by p, so there's no
other scale in the problem.
OK?
So that's kind of
interesting, and one can make
some predictions with that.
This is actually
something that's
also investigated these days,
both from a string theory
point of view as well as
in cold atoms, so that's
why conformal symmetries
are always fun to play with.
There's also another set of
symmetries that this theory has
in this limit, which
is also interesting.
And that is, like HQET, there's
an enhanced spin symmetry.
This time, the
enhanced spin symmetry
comes about by combining
spin and isospin.
And this is a symmetry that's
known as Wigner's SU(4)
symmetry.
So Wigner-- I don't know
how many years ago--
noticed-- long, long
ago, Wigner noticed
that nuclei tend to
have a symmetry, which
is a combination of spin and
isospin, into a full SU(4).
And we can understand
actually partly
where that comes from this
effective field theory.
So what is this SU(4)?
Think of it as just
transforming the nucleon field
under a way where you could mix
up the spin and the isospin.
So if sigma is for the spin,
tau is for the isospin,
then some combined
transformation
where I can mix up
the mu and nus-- we
just have some set
of generators where
I label them by mu and nu.
Sigma mu here is 1, comma,
sigma vector, tau nu, 1, comma,
tau vector for the isospin.
If you just take the 1 from both
of them, that's baryon number,
and that would turn
the SU(4) into a U(4),
so you can remove that
generator if you like.
So there's a U(1), as well,
but the nontrivial part,
where you take either this
or that or both is an SU(4).
So we can think about this
symmetry with our theory
if we write it as follows.
So take the interaction terms
that we've been talking about
and write them in a
slightly different basis.
Just take these
two-to-two scattering
terms, which had no derivatives.
And I'll write them in a
slightly different basis.
Before, we wrote them in
sort of the physical basis,
where we had 3S1 and 1S0.
That's what we did last time.
But there's other
possible bases,
and I can write them in this
basis, singlet triplet basis.
And the advantage of this
basis is this thing here
is just SU(4) symmetric.
And if you want to write down in
relation to the previous basis,
you can work that out.
I'll just tell you what it
would be by writing down
what the coefficients here
are in terms of the ones
we had before.
So if we go back
to the basis where
we had coefficients for the 3S1
channel and the 1S0 channel,
then this c 0 s becomes
this combination,
and c 0 t is this combination.
Now, in nature-- so one way
you could have SU(4) symmetry
would just be for the
scattering lengths,
the physical parameter, c 0
1S0 and c 0 3S1, to be equal.
But in nature, they're
not equal at all.
In fact, their scattering
lengths have different signs.
There's no sense in
which they're equal.
So what is the sense in
which we have this symmetry?
The sense in which
we have this symmetry
is the fact that
if the scattering
lengths are both infinity, then
both couplings are just this.
So the fact that the scattering
lengths have different signs
but are both large makes them
close to this fixed point,
which then gives this symmetry.
So because of what I just said
for a goes to infinity, c 0 s,
which is sort of equal--
some symmetric combination of
these two that's become equal--
would just become 4 pi over
m mu, and this is for a 1S0
and a 3S1, both
going to infinity.
This goes to minus infinity.
And then the triplet
one, if we just
work out what it is
from our formulas
for those other couplings--
We can just work
out the combination
from formulas we had
last time, and we
see that as the
a's go to infinity,
this coupling vanishes.
OK?
So when we're in the limit
where both of the couplings
become equal, or if we
use this basis, where
this coupling becomes 0,
we just have this N dagger
N squared operator.
Then we have this
SU(4) symmetry.
One of the problems on
this new problem set
is to think about to
what degree you still
have that symmetry when
you think about higher body
operators, three-body
and four-body.
And there's actually some
very nice little group theory
arguments where you can
basically figure out
to what degree you
have that symmetry
in the higher-body
operators, and it turns out
that it's also present there.
And that is one way of thinking
about why Wigner's symmetries
exist in nature.
It's not that we're in any sense
having scattering lengths that
are similar in
these two channels,
but since they're both large
we're close to the same--
we're close to
these fixed points,
which have this symmetry.
OK?
So it's like HQET,
in a sense, where
we didn't have heavy
quark spin symmetry
when the masses are finite,
but if the charm mass and the B
mass are both
infinite, then there's
this new symmetry that pops up.
It's kind of like that.
All right, so rather than
talk about the symmetries
in any more detail than that,
what I wanted to do is actually
do something a little
different with this theory.
So there's lots of things
we could discuss here.
But the thing I want
to discuss is actually
treating a bound state
in a field theory.
This field theory has
a very nice property
that we can
calculate everything.
So we can actually
see how you're
supposed to treat bound states
exactly because we can actually
just look for the pole
that corresponds to that
bound state in this theory.
That's what we're going to do.
So usually if you
have a bound state,
it's either something
that's nonperturbative
that you have trouble
dealing with analytically,
like in QCD, or Coulombic--
even then, the calculations get
kind of hairy, although
you can deal with it there.
But here, the calculations
are very simple,
so we can really follow all
the steps of properly dealing
with a bound state.
And the bound state has
something to do with nature.
It's a state of nature
called the deuteron.
So the deuteron is a bound
state of a neutron and a proton.
It has isospin 0, spin 1,
so it's in this 3S1 state
that we talked about.
And when you want to look for
a bound state in field theory,
what you do--
you may have heard of this
from the lattice point of view.
What you do is you write down
some interpolating field that
has overlap with that state.
So what would that be for us?
That would be this
operator that we
called p i 3S1, which had the
quantum numbers for i equals 0
and s equals 1.
And we can build an
interpolating field out
of our N transpose N.
And actually, any interpolating
field that we write down here
is equally good.
The lattice QCD
people like to tune
what they write down
in order to improve
the overlap with the state.
But for our purposes the
simplest possible thing
will be enough.
And then you can
ask the question,
is the deuteron in the theory?
And to answer that
question, you can just
look for the pole that would
correspond to that state.
And the advantage
of this theory is
that we can just look for
that pole analytically.
So let's do that.
So I'll write down
a Green's function
for the two-particle
state, which
is just the time-order product
of two of these interpolating
fields.
And then ask the
question, if I look
at that time-order
product, is there
a pole that would correspond
to this state, i.e.,
somewhere is there a pole
which would behave as follows?
Some kind of z factor,
and then, in this case,
because of the way
we've scaled energies,
we would just be looking
for a pole that's
when you're in the energy--
at some negative energy
corresponding to the binding
energy of that state.
So remember that we pulled
out the mass of the nucleon.
That wasn't in our Lagrangian.
So really, if you
think about what
the sort of energy of this
state is, it's two nucleons,
so it's got the energy
of those two nucleons,
but then there's
a little bit less
because it's a bound state.
And this is the amount
by how much less.
And so the energy for
the pole is negative.
E bar is less than 0 because
it's much less than the two
nucleon mass.
So this E bar is the
two nuclear center
of mass energy, which
in the conventions
we were using last time--
we had energy E over 2
for each of the nucleons,
so the sum would be E. There's
the kinetic term, as well.
So what are the diagrams that
we would consider to do this?
Well, at lowest order it's just
our friends the bubble sum.
And in fact, when you
go to higher orders,
we also had bubbles there.
So to answer this question,
we insert the field.
We create two nucleons.
And then they can interact
with c 0's, and then we
annihilate them with
our interpolating field.
So these are just
our c 0 bubbles.
OK?
And those are very
easy to compute.
It's just the geometric series
that we already computed.
And instead of having two
nucleons in and two nucleons
out, we just have
this deuteron state in
and deuteron state out.
OK?
So the Green's function
starts with one of these
and then just iterates into
a geometric series, where
sigma I could define as
two-particle irreducible c
0 graphs, so sort of taking
out the c 0 iterations, so
the sigma 1 that I'm
talking about here
is just this bubble
all by itself.
And that's something
that we computed
before and in these
renormalization schemes
that we like.
Just comes out to be this.
So there's an m out
front, m nucleon.
It's not-- that's
an m, not a mu.
And then in terms of this E bar,
it just comes out to be that.
So you could think of
making a positive energy
by taking E bar to minus E
bound, which is less than 0.
And then the square root
would be square root of m E B.
And it's convenient to
define that to be something,
so I'll call it
gamma B. So that's
some quantity greater than 0.
And with this little
notation, this square root
of minus E bar, minus i
0 is equal to minus i p.
And we're looking
for whether that
would be sort of going over
to this gamma B. Sorry,
so this is equal to gamma B.
So gamma B is just
like a momentum
version of the bound state
energy absorbing the extra i.
OK?
This is what it would
have been previously,
but now it's gamma B.
So we know what G was.
We already computed it earlier.
G was just proportional
to 1 over a plus i p.
And now if I just make
that replacement, which
is why I wanted to derive that,
because I wanted to just see
how I would replace the i p, it
becomes 1 over a minus gamma B.
So gamma B is a
kinematic variable.
It's like a momentum.
But it's the right
kinematic variable
to be talking about
for the bound state.
It's a positive thing.
And you can see there's a pole.
OK?
So there's the
pole corresponding
to the deuteron state.
It just corresponds to gamma
equals 1 over a of the 3S1,
which in nature is like 36
m e V is greater than 0.
If you looked at the other
channel, the 1S0 channel,
then the scattering
linked with negative,
so then both terms would be
negative, and there's no pole.
OK?
So for the 3S1 channel,
we have a pole.
That's the physical
deuteron state.
For the other channel,
there is no pole.
And the binding energy that
you would get from this
is gamma B squared over
m, our conventions,
which, if you calculate
it, is 1.4 m e V,
and that's not
ridiculously different
than the real binding energy
of the deuteron, which was 2.2
m e V. OK?
It's not-- it's the
right order of magnitude.
All right, so
that's the deuteron.
It exists in this theory,
and we could perturbatively
correct towards this
correct binding energy.
OK?
So this deuteron really
exists in the field theory,
and that means we can calculate
properties of the deuteron
with this field theory.
We can calculate
scattering processes that
involve this bound
state, and it's
no more difficult than
doing calculations
that we would normally
do with free fields.
And we just have to--
if we want to do something
with the deuteron,
we have to go to the right pole.
That's basically what
it boils down to.
So in order to show you
really how to do that,
I'm going to give one
example of calculating
something nontrivial
that involves a deuteron.
So we'll calculate a form
factor for the deuteron.
So this is a nice
example, if you like,
of really showing you how
to use the LSZ formula,
which you learned
about it in a very sort
of abstract way at some point,
how to use it for bound notes.
Because here we have a bound
state exists in the theory,
and if we want to derive
properties of that bound state,
we'd better properly use the LSZ
formula for that bound state.
Let's see how that works.
OK, so what we'd
like to do, so we'd
like to have-- we have
some deuteron state,
and we'd like to take
the matrix element
with the
electromagnetic current.
And if you work out what
possible form factors you can
have for this matrix element,
there's actually three.
And I'm not going to
spend much time talking
about the sort of
different couplings
with spin and stuff
that correspond
to these different
cases, but I'll
list them for you,
at least, provide
you some additional
references if you
want to dig deeper into this.
So there's a magnetic, electric,
and quadrupole form factor.
The charge of the
deuteron tells us
that this electric
form factor at 2
squared equals 0 should be 1.
The magnetic form factor
is like the magnetic form
factor for an electron in the
sense that, if you go to q
squared equals 0, then that's
giving you the magnetic moment.
But here it's the
magnetic moment
of the deuteron, not
the magnetic moment
of the electron.
That's a nontrivial
number in this case,
whereas here it's just 1
because charge is conserved.
And if we wanted to think
about putting electromagnetism
into the nucleon theory,
which we haven't so far,
then we would turn
our derivatives
into covariant derivatives.
So D mu nucleon--
we have to write down a
charge matrix that couples--
that takes into account
the proton has charge
but the neutron doesn't.
So this is that charge
matrix for electromagnetism.
OK?
So it's not difficult.
So that's easy enough.
Just change your derivatives
into covariant derivatives
for both D 0 and D
partial and D vector.
There's also some
additional operators
that you have to write down.
So there's operators,
for example,
that are just
contact interactions
with the electric
magnetic fields
in principle, and the first such
one that shows up, just by way
of sort of telling you the
range of possibilities,
would be something like this,
where you just have a sigma dot
B magnetic field insertion.
This is the magnetic field
for electromagnetism.
And so if you want to think
about the type of Feynman
diagram you'd draw for this,
you'd have four nucleons,
and then you'd just have a
photon coming out, right?
And if you want to think about
where that could possibly
come from, there is one really
easy thing to think about,
would just be to
have a pion exchange,
and maybe it's pi minus.
And the photon couples
to the pi minus
because it's got
electric charge.
And when I integrate
out the pion,
then I just get something
that looks like this.
It could be any exchange.
It could be a real
minus, or anything
would give an operator
that looks like that.
OK?
So there's additional
contact interactions
involving electromagnetism,
and you gauge the derivatives.
Then you can put
electromagnetism
into the theory.
It gets a little
more nontrivial then.
And that's what we
need to do if we
want to talk about
electromagnetism
coupling for the deuteron.
But I'm mostly interested
here in how the LSZ works.
So what does LSZ say?
So LSZ says that if I have
this state, p prime, J out,
J mu electromagnetism, p i n--
i is like a spin index because
we have a triplet under spin--
then this is how you
should calculate it.
So q is like the--
well, I guess I'm in momentum
space all of a sudden.
Well, no. q is just
p minus p prime.
E and E bar are related to
the p and the p prime also.
And what I do is I have some
z factor out front, which
is the bound state z factor.
LSZ tells me to be careful
about that z factor.
These guys here are just
two-point functions,
and that's because I have
to truncate the lines.
This is truncation by
two-point functions,
but they're two-point
functions for the bound
state, so two lines.
And then this is the
three-point functions.
OK?
So for the
three-point functions,
what would the time-order
product be for that?
It's a time-order
product of three things.
So the two-point function
we already defined.
It was just the
time-order product
of the two deuteron fields.
And the three-point function has
an additional electromagnetic
current, which we would
formulate-- you know,
all the couplings
here are this way
that I was talking
about over there.
So in terms of diagrams, which
are easier to think about
in some ways than
time-order products,
we have the two-point
function, which,
if I just define all possible
two-point functions as G--
and this is the thing that
was our two-particle--
was our irreducible
c 0 contributions,
plus iterations of c0's, right?
Since the c 0 is a
nonperturbative coupling,
we have to iterate, and
this is what we already
said you could
define as the summing
of that geometric series,
and then just define it
as something which is the
full Green's function in terms
of this irreducible piece
in the usual sort of way.
And then, for this
other G, I'll draw
a blob, which I'll also call G,
but with an additional photon
hanging out.
Those are all
three-point functions.
And in a kind of a
similar notation,
I can have kind of
an irreducible piece,
and then I can have
iterations with c 0's.
Et cetera.
And if I sum up those
irreducible diagrams,
I can write the full
Green's function
in terms of the
irreducible pieces,
again, in a similar
sort of notation.
It's just gamma, which
carries the indices,
and then there's just
a couple of-- now
there's geometric series on
both sides, so when I sum it
up I get that.
OK, so this is giving you
the ingredients that we
need to plug into this formula.
We need G inverse.
This is G. The two-point--
we need the G mu
i J, which we can
write in terms of the
irreducible guy, like that.
Then the last thing we need
is this bound state factor.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: That cofactor
has a contribution
that you just erased?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah,
what I really--
I'm kind of using
a shorthand here
with this t product
for all the diagrams
that come from what I was
talking about over there.
Yeah, I kind of wrote it as
an electromagnetic current,
but really what I mean by
it is sort of all the ways
that electromagnetism can
appear in the effective theory.
So you can think of
formulating a current
in the effective theory by just
sort of looking for one photon,
lopping it off, and
then writing down
that operator, all the
operators, and that's really
what I mean by this J mu.
Any other questions?
OK, so what's the
final thing we need,
which is the bound
state z factor.
So that's-- let me look back at
this kind of form that we had
for G. We said it's i z, but now
let's denote the fact that z is
really the principal
function of E bar,
and it's really the
residue of the pole.
And what z is, z that appears
in the formula over there,
it's z at the pole,
so that's where
I set E bar equal to minus
B D in the numerator.
So this is the
residue of the pole.
And with a little
bit of manipulation,
we can write that
as the following.
We can relate it to a
derivative at the pole.
OK?
So take the inverse,
take a derivative
to sort of get just this factor.
Take an inverse again.
You can extract off that
residue, killing off
some other pieces by
going to the pole.
OK?
So I won't go through
the derivation
of that little
manipulation, but it's
a straightforward consequence.
And if you put in
kind of the formula
that we had over here for
G, and if you do that,
then you can write a
formula in terms of sigma.
And after that kind of
manipulation, it's--
again, just some algebra
to show that this is true.
So now we can put all
the pieces together.
We have this formula,
we have this formula,
we have this formula.
Put them into the
formula up there.
And what we find is that we can
write the kind of result of it
using LSZ in a kind
of very compact way,
just in terms of irreducible
things, c 0 irreducible things.
And it's not just the
irreducible three-point
functions.
There is a contribution from
the two-point function, which
is in this case D sigma D E bar,
where you take E bar and E bar
prime, incoming and
outgoing energies, to be
the right energies for
the bound states, which
is minus the binding energy.
OK?
So this factor came from here.
There was a sigma
squared in the numerator,
but when I take the inverse
of two of these guys,
there's a sigma squared
in the denominator,
and those canceled.
The inverse of these guys
also had factors of 1
plus i c 0 sigma
in the numerator,
and that canceled
these factors here,
so the only thing left is the
gamma and the D sigma D E bar.
OK?
So that's what LSZ
says in this situation.
And it's actually important to
take this factor into account.
If you didn't take this
factor into account,
you wouldn't even
preserve, for example,
that the charge of
the deuteron is 1.
It's quite important.
If you look at this
at lowest order
and you just look at the
electromagnetic current
for the electric case, and
you can do that with J 0,
looking at the D 0, and we can
use our previous calculations
to figure out what the
two-point function is.
And when I go to
the pole, it's just
this factor, where
gamma B would be
set equal to exactly
the binding energy.
OK?
So that's just from
the trivial diagram.
And then the first
contribution that
comes into the three-point
function can be calculated.
It's pretty straightforward.
It gives a tan
inverse, actually.
And that just
comes from coupling
to the electromagnetic proton
that's inside the deuteron.
So this is the proton, which
has an electromagnetic coupling.
This is the neutron.
OK?
And that gives this formula.
You take the ratio.
You get the lowest-order
form factor.
This is a systematically
provable thing,
so you can do NLO.
You can do NNLO, et cetera, OK?
So we can really calculate
properties of the deuteron
and check whether they
work experimentally,
and this works extremely
well experimentally.
You actually don't
see the violation
of charge conservation in the
form factor until you do NLO.
Then you really see that
you need this guy in order
to make sure that the
charge is conserved.
There would be some
pieces that would show up
that would seem like
they were correcting
the charge, violating
electromagnetism,
magnetic gauge
variance until you--
but then when you
put the z factor in,
the z factor contribution
in, everything is nice.
And this theory
has actually been
used to do phenomenology,
so just to give you
some examples of that.
So you can do a process
like neutron on proton
produces a deuteron
and a photon,
which is something that shows
up in Big Bang nucleosynthesis.
And it's been
calculated to N 4 LO
in this effective field theory.
[CHUCKLES] OK?
And it provides the
most accurate way
of determining the process
for Big Bang nucleosynthesis.
You could reverse it, talk
about deuteron breakup.
You could do processes with
neutrinos on deuterons.
So you could have
neutrino-deuteron scattering
to proton-proton
e minus, which is
the charge current
process at SNO
or the neutral current
process at SNO.
All of these things are
within the realm of things
that you can talk about in this
effective field theory, OK?
So it has some uses.
Let me do one more process.
So you could look at neutron--
nucleon-nucleon to
nucleon-nucleon plus an axion.
And there's sort
of a lesson here.
So if you look at how the
axion couples to the nucleon,
it's derivatively
coupled, so you have
a gradient of the axion field.
And there's two
possible coupling
that you can write
down, just to consider
the sort of lowest dimension
in our power counting.
And this is a
process that actually
is important for
bounding axion physics,
for example, axions in the
sun, to worry about how
they couple to nucleons.
And the thing that's
actually important
is, if you're thinking
about this kind of process,
you have to decide kinematically
what region are you looking at.
If you're interested
in bounds from the sun,
you're interested in a situation
where the energy of the axion
is of order of the
energy of the nucleons,
but the momentum of
the axion is much less,
so I'll call that k axion is
much less than p nucleon, OK?
So from a power
counting perspective,
the energies are the same size,
but the momentum of the axion,
which is a relativistic
particle and is
comparable to the
energy, is much less
since the nucleon momentum is
much bigger than its energy.
Remember that the energy
goes like p squared over m,
so the momentum are bigger.
And if that's the situation
that you're in, then when
you're doing a
Lagrangian like this
you have to be careful
about implementing something
like that.
And the way that
it gets implemented
is by a multipole
expansion, which
we'll have an
opportunity to talk
more about in the near future.
But basically what
that corresponds to
is that you've got to
make sure that you're
sort of exchanging energy
between these operators,
but not momenta.
That's what happens
at lowest order.
So if you make this
expansion in the Lagrangian,
it corresponds to setting the
spatial components of the axion
field to 0, OK?
So this is like
doing an expansion
around x vector equals 0, the
same thing in position space
is this expansion here.
So this is-- implements the
k much less than p expansion.
OK?
So that would actually
be the operator
that you would use to
couple axions to nucleon.
Now, the interesting
thing about this operator,
which ties into what we
started talking about today,
is that once you
take x equals 0,
the things that
you're left with here
are related to conserved
charges at the SU(4) symmetry.
So Q mu nu, which is an integral
over all space of N dagger
sigma mu tau nu N-- that's
the charge of SU(4).
And the reason that
it's related to that
is because, once I
take x equals 0 here,
once I do the integral d 4 x
of the Lagrangian, the time--
this still depends on time
but doesn't depend on space,
so I can move the
d 3 x through, just
let it act on this,
just let it act on that,
and then I get Q mu nu.
Well, Q0j and Q--
or Qj0 and Qj3,
so this guy here.
Color.
Qj3, Qj0.
This guy here.
Qj3.
And that actually has
nontrivial consequences
because charges, if they're
charges of a symmetry,
are time-independent.
So even though in principle
I didn't make any assumptions
about the time dependence
here, and these operators
could exchange energy,
if I know that they
are related to charges of
the effective field theory,
then charges are conserved.
There's no time dependence.
So the charges of the field
theory are time-dependent.
And what that means then is
that this is time-independent,
and there's actually
no energy exchange.
So the axion can only
sort of exchange energy--
the only way the axion can
couple is with zero energy.
And since it's derivatively
coupled, it has zero energy,
it has zero momentum,
and there's no coupling.
So this limit that we talked
about is a symmetry limit.
The axion just doesn't couple.
OK?
So there we're predicting
something falling
through kind of the
consequences of symmetry
on this effective
a field theory.
We're predicting
something about how
axions couple to the nucleons.
So if you look sort of
through the possible processes
that you could have, you could
have two nucleons in a 3S1
state try to produce an axion,
and that actually vanishes
irrespective of the
scattering lengths
because you're
coupling here to spin,
and that is always a good charge
of the nonrelativistic theory.
But there is a way that you
could have the process go,
where you switch from a
1S0 state to a 3S1 state,
and this guy vanishes
if the scattering
lengths go to infinity.
So if you ignored what I just
said and you ignored this here,
and you just went ahead
and calculated the Feynman
diagrams, you would just
find that the amplitude
to this thing is proportional
to this kind of factor
that we saw before.
And since the scattering
lengths are large,
it's vanishing if the scattering
lengths go to infinity.
OK?
So at lowest order,
the effective theory,
it's suppressed, this process,
and that has implications
for of course the phenomenology.
You could also put in
higher-dimension operators,
like the c 2's,
and then of course
you can get a
contribution, but that's
higher order of
the power counting,
and that affects
how the axion could
be constrained in the sun.
OK?
So that gives you a
little bit of a feeling
for what you can do with
this effective field theory
and how you can kind
of exploit symmetry,
as well as the calculability
of the effective theory
to make lots of
interesting predictions.
OK?
So any questions about that?
All right.
So that's all I have to say
about that effective theory.
So we're now going to move on
to our final effective field
theory, [SIGHS] to
soft-collinear effective
theory.
So what I intend to do with
this part of the course, which
will take us through
the rest of the year,
is I'm going to hand out
lecture notes for you to read,
which I'm going to write.
[CHUCKLES]
So I haven't done that yet.
I'm going to continue to post--
I mean, I have some
rough copy of them,
but I'm going to make it
pretty and beautiful for you,
or more beautiful
than it currently is.
I'm also going to continue to
post the lecture notes of what
I present in lecture,
so you'll have
sort of two versions
that you can read,
either the LaTeX version
or the handwritten version,
and depending on your taste you
can look at one or the other.
So what we'll do today is we'll
just sort of briefly introduce
ourselves to this
effective theory.
And by way of introduction
to any effective theory,
the kind of things that we
should talk about or why--
so we'll talk about why.
And then we should talk about
what the degrees of freedom
are.
And in this case,
we'll also talk
about kind of what are
convenient coordinates
to be using for this
effective theory.
So that's what we'll
start covering today.
So what is SCET?
So it's an effective
field theory
that you can use
for multiple things.
One is for energetic hadrons.
So the energy of
the hadron should
be something that's a
large scale, which I'll
call Q, conventional notation.
And by energetic it
means much more energetic
than the mass of the hadrons,
which is of order lambda QCD.
It's also an effective
theory for energetic jets.
And the situation is in some
ways similar to the hadrons.
You have a jet energy that's
large, of order some Q,
and that's much
bigger than the jet
mass, which is the root squared
of some forward momentum.
And by the name, you should
also imagine that really
what it is something
to do with QCD.
Well, maybe not by the name, but
it is something to do with QCD.
And it's kind of what you
get if you start with QCD
and you focus your
attention on a certain set
of interactions,
which are collinear
and soft interactions.
So we've met several different
examples of effective field
theory so far in the course.
Some of them were bottom-up.
Some of them were top-down.
This is going to be a
top-down effective field
theory, just like HQET was
a top-down effective field
theory.
So we'll be able to start
with the QCD Lagrangian
and derive this theory
by taking certain limits,
and that's what we'll do.
So why study this?
We'll come to that in a bit.
But what are the
kind of features
of this from an effective
field theory point of view
that make it interesting?
Well, we'll talk about the
answer to both those questions.
So first, why study this?
What's this effective
theory good for?
So one thing that's good for
is understanding factorization.
And if you think
about what we're
doing when we probe for
short-distance physics
at the LHC, we're probing
for short-distance physics
by colliding things
at high energy.
So we're carrying
out hard collisions,
energetic collisions
of particles.
So the fact that this
effective field theory
deals with energetic
particles may ring a bell
as it being something
useful for understanding
short-distance physics.
And so what this effective
theory allows you to do
is disentangle the
short-distance physics
that you're interested in from
the longer-distance physics
that's associated to binding
together into hadrons
or producing these
energetic jets.
So it's really disentangling
the long- and short-distance
physics in the standard
model, or the standard model
plus new physics.
And basically what
that amounts to is
disentangling long- and
short-distance physics in QCD.
So let me write it this way.
Disentangling the physics
of QCD with addition
of electroweak or BSM physics.
It requires a
separation of scales.
We have to decide what's short
distance, what's long distance.
If we're interested in
a process like the LHC,
where we're colliding
together hadrons,
then that's of course
absolutely necessary
because the hadrons are
long-distance things,
and we're interested in
short-distance physics,
and we can do that with SCET,
so that's perhaps the biggest
motivation for us today.
When we make hard
collisions, these jets
and energetic hadrons
are very common.
They're the most common
things that are produced.
And from a physics
point of view,
that means that there's many,
many different processes
that you can actually use this
effective field theory for,
and that's one of the
reasons it's popular.
So I want to give
you some examples.
You could do deep
inelastic scattering.
In this effective theory,
deep inelastic scattering
involves a hard collision.
And even classic textbook
deep inelastic scattering
is made very much simpler by
this effective field theory,
and we'll show you that with
one of our examples later on.
You could do Drell-Yan with
either protons and antiprotons
or protons and protons.
You could do Higgs
production, and people
use this effective field theory
to study Higgs production
at the LHC.
You could do, by way of trying
to make the examples more
varied, e plus e minus to jets.
This is another thing that the
effective theory is used for.
You could do quarkonium
physics, e plus or minus,
producing a J psi
and an X. Here,
you need a combination
if the J psi
is produced at large energy of
kind of a nonrelativistic QCD
for this cc-bar
bound state, as well
as an SCT for the fact that
it's an energetic state.
So this would be
actually a combination
of two different
effective field theories.
People use it for thinking
about jet substructure.
So all sorts of
things that you might
be interested in and
thinking about having
to do with hard scattering.
There's also
another way that you
could get energetic
particles, even
if you don't force
them to be energetic,
and that is if you had a
very heavy particle decaying.
So if you had a B meson decaying
and it decayed to light stuff,
this would also be the right
effective theory for that.
So for example, in the
process B to s gamma,
this effective
theory plays a role,
in the process B to D pi,
where the pion comes out very
energetic, or B
to pi pi, which is
something very interesting
for studying CP violation.
You can use this
effective theory
to understand the short-
and long-distance physics
of those processes, as well.
OK?
And this is coming about
because this B meson is heavy.
So that's the sort
of range of examples,
and it's not really
complete in any sense.
There's just lots
of different things
you can study with this theory.
So this I already said,
but let me write it.
I sort of alluded to
separating perturbative physics
at short distances from
the nonperturbative physics
at long distances.
And the nonperturbative
physics, if you're lucky,
may be only encoded in
parton distribution functions
or something if you're
doing a p-p collision,
and you'd like to separate that
from shorter-distance physics
that you could calculate
perturbatively,
and this is a way of doing that.
And then there's a
renormalization group
in this effective theory, and
that renormalization group
actually allows you to
do something cool, too,
and that is that you
can sum up something
called Sudakov logarithms,
which are algorithms
that appear in our canonical way
as alpha s times a logarithm.
But instead of one logarithm,
you actually get two.
And so the renormalization
group in this effective theory
will allow you to handle
those Sudakov logarithms.
OK?
So that's some set of things.
What are we going to have to
do that we haven't done before?
What are the kind
of new ingredients
that we're going to run into?
So sort of a prelude
to things to come,
or another way of
saying what makes
SCET different from
the effective theories
we've seen so far.
Let's have a little
list for that, as well.
So perhaps the most
interesting one
is that we are going to
have more than one field
for each degree of freedom.
So we're going to have
more than one field--
that's not quite the
right way of saying it.
We're going to have
more than one field
for the same particle.
Just a slightly
different statement.
So we're going to have a
field, which we'll talk about,
that I'll call c sub n,
which is a collinear quark
field for some quark,
say an up quark.
And there's also going to
be another field, q sub
s, which is a soft quark
field for the same up quark.
So let's say for the
up quark [INAUDIBLE]
just to make it definite.
And the reason that we're
going to have these two
different fields
is because they're
going to describe
the same particle
but in different regions
of momentum space.
So if you like, they're
describing different degrees
of freedom of the same
particle because they're
in different regions
of momentum space.
But it still is
the same particle,
and that's not something
we've had to deal with in any
of our examples so far.
We always had one field
for each particle.
Now we're going to
have more than one,
so that's one complication.
The second one we have
actually encountered before,
and that is that we're
going to integrate out
off-shell modes of a field, but
not the entire particle, not
the entire degree of freedom.
And we encountered that
when we talked about HQET.
So the situation here will
be a little more complicated
than HQET, but this
second point is like HQET,
and we'll use some
of our experience
that we gained
from studying HQET.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
soft and collinear?
Which one--
IAIN STEWART: It
never can be both.
[CHUCKLES]
AUDIENCE: Why?
IAIN STEWART: We'll
have to decide
whether it's one or the other.
So an important thing--
exactly this issue of which
it is an important thing
because you're going
to be describing
with these fields
certain fluctuations,
and you don't want overlap.
So you're going to have to-- if
you point your finger somewhere
in momentum space,
we'll have to decide
is it in this category
or this category.
It can't be in both.
But that will be
important in a bit.
That will come back.
AUDIENCE: So you're partioning--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, two
regions, and no overlap.
But we'll have to work a little
bit to make sure that's true.
Yeah, we want to
make sure to not
have double counting in the
effective theory, where you
could write down something
that looks like it could
be described by either one.
And if that was true, then
we would have a problem.
So another thing that makes
SCET interesting from an EFT
point of view is that
we have convolutions.
So usually in an
effective theory
you think about having
multiple operators that
have the same quantum numbers.
We sum over those operators,
say at some order in the power
counting, sum over i of Wilson
coefficients times operators.
And this sum becomes a
continuous integral in SCET.
You'll see how that works.
And that actually
leads to convolutions.
In fact, exactly this
little manipulation
here is what leads to the
convolution of the parton
distribution function
with hard scattering.
If you think about this
operator is describing--
the matrix elements
of this operator
is describing a parton
distribution function.
The Wilson's coefficients is
describing the hard scattering.
Exactly this integral
is what leads
to the integral the convolutes
together parton distribution
functions and hard
scattering matrix elements.
Come back to that.
So there's going to
be a power counting
for this effective theory.
And we're going to call the
power counting parameter
lambda, and it's not going to
be related to the mass dimension
of fields.
So we'll have to figure out
how to do the power counting.
There's going to be something
called the Wilson line, which
will show up all over the
place in this effective theory.
So these are lines in space
that are coupled to the gauge
field, A. And we'll see
why they're showing up,
but it's related
actually to the fact
that this effective theory has
a very interesting and perhaps
subtle gauge symmetry structure.
One way of actually already
seeing why that is true
is because I told
you over here that we
have two types of quarks.
Everything I say about quarks
is also true of gluons,
so there's going to be
two types of gluons,
an A n gluon and an A s gluon.
And once there's
two types of gluons,
you should say, well, what's
the gauge group of this gluon
and what's the gauge
group for that gluon?
Well, they're both
the same gauge group.
It's QCD.
So we partitioned QCD in
some kind of weird way,
where we have two fields
for the gauge group,
rather than just one.
Part of that story
is going to be
related to these Wilson lines.
And finally, one final
kind of interesting thing
that's going to
happen is we're going
to see when we do one-loop
calculations in this theory
that we find 1 over epsilon
squared divergences.
So usually, when you do
an effective field theory
calculation, at one loop you
find a 1 over epsilon pole,
not a 1 over epsilon squared.
And I denote it by epsilon
u v because both poles here
require u v renormalization.
We need to add a counterterm
to cancel this double pole.
And exactly the presence
of that double pole
is what leads to these Sudakov
logs that I was mentioning,
the fact that we
have these double
logs going along
with each alpha s.
So we'll see that taking care
of this with renormalization,
which is little different than
the renormalization you're
used to, will allow us to sum
up those Sudakov logarithms, OK?
So that's the kind
of hint of the things
that we will be studying.
You're not supposed to
understand any of them
yet unless you've
study SCET, but we
will understand all of these
by the end of the course.
OK?
Any question?
Anything I missed on my list?
[CHUCKLES] All right.
So let's spend some time talking
about degrees of freedom.
The way I like to think
about degrees of freedom
for any effective
field theory is
this is where you have to
think about the physics of what
you're doing, OK?
So let's think about
some physical process.
I'm going to consider two
different physical processes.
Actually, today, I'll only
start talking about one of them,
and then we'll talk about
the other one next time.
Think about some
physical process
and try to identify what the
right degrees of freedom are.
So you could look at
the process of a B meson
changing into a D
meson and a pion.
The advantage of
starting with this one
is that we've already
talked about HQET,
so we understand how to
do B mesons and D mesons,
and we just have to
understand how to do the pion.
So we have a B meson.
Let's think about it
in the rest frame.
Decays to a very heavy D
meson and a very light pion.
So the D meson we
can treat with HQET.
The B meson we can
treat with HQET.
The problem is this pion
because it's very energetic.
If you look at the momentum
of that pion and the way
I've drawn it, and you
put in some numbers just
to get a sense of what
we're talking about,
then it's got an
energy, which is
slightly bigger
than the momentum,
and that's because
it has a mass,
but it's a pretty small mass.
e squared minus p squared
is 135 m e V squared.
And so if you look
at that, you see
that this momentum
of the pion is
very close to the light cone.
The light cone would be
if these two were equal.
That's what a massless
particle would do.
A pion is pretty light, and
it's moving relativistically,
and there's no sense in which
we can think about 2.3 G e
V as a small scale.
We're not going to expand
in 2.3 G e V over m B
because that's a
pretty lousy expansion.
So p pi mu here is
basically some scale
times a light-like vector,
where n mu is 1, 0, 0, minus 1,
and that's to a
good approximation.
We'll see how good over there.
So we're going to use
light-like vectors to talk
about particles like a pion.
So n mu is a light-like vector.
n squared is 0.
And what we're going
to be expanding in
is, instead of expanding
in Q over m B, Q over pion,
we're going to think about
the dynamics with this scale Q
scale, 2.3 G e V as being
much bigger than lambda QCD.
So we're going to
use, for particles
like this pion that
are very energetic,
light cone coordinates.
So when you have a
light cone vector like n
and you want to decompose
any vector in terms of it,
you need another
auxiliary vector,
which I'm going to call n bar.
So these are two
light-like vectors.
They both square to 0.
And the reason I
need two of them
is because I need some
notion of orthogonality,
so you should think of n bar as
like the complementary vector
to n.
It's the dual vector in
the orthogonal sense.
So with those two vectors,
you can decompose any vector
in terms of--
use them as a basis.
This is how it works,
my conventions.
So you have two components that
you can decompose along n and n
bar, and the value of the
momentum along that direction
is the complementary
vector dotted into p.
And so we usually--
with this notation, we
call n bar dot p p minus.
So that's just a shorthand.
And n dot p is p plus, OK?
So it's going to be
useful to decompose things
along these directions
for the same reason
that you kind of saw here,
that the pion was naturally
decomposing itself along
a particular light-like
direction.
So we're going to want to
do that more generally,
and that's how we'll
do it for momenta.
If we talk about p squared, and
I just square the components
here, n dotted into
"perp" is 0, and bar
dotted into "perp" is 0.
There's a nontrivial--
that's square root of 0.
That's square root of 0.
There's a nontrivial
cross-term between those two,
which is this.
This guy can be squared.
If we use our shorthand,
then it's this.
And if we want to use Euclidean
notation, then I can--
I'll switch and I'll say
that p "perp" squared, which
is a Minkowski
negative quantity,
is minus p vector
"perp" squared,
where p vector "perp"
squared is Euclidean.
So sometimes I'll-- use for
both of those notations.
All right, so I think we're
out of time for today.
We'll continue with this
discussion of degrees
of freedom next time and
talk a little bit more
about coordinates, as well.